I have a question for cernovich
the deliberations in the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial have now gone on for
over two days
what do you think that means
well that's what I was talking about
earlier if I were his lawyer what I
think it would mean is that if you can
get a mistrial without prejudice you
want to roll the dice again because
you're only the only outcome for you at
that point is it's tending towards bad
if I had to guess I would say that
there's one or two holdouts to convict
it's the vast majority of people who are
not guilty a couple of activists got on
that jury and they're going to hang
because usually you hang the juror the
other way usually your your challenge is
getting one or two people usually need
two because one person is always going
to back down to vote not guilty and get
the retrial this I think is the opposite
because he's so clearly like if we were
the left and he were convicted my God
because he's so clearly not guilty it's
not even up for a reasonable discussion
if they were to get a mistrial without
prejudice would they get a new jury yep
it'd be uh all over finding an untainted
jury at this point but on top of that do
they recall all the witnesses yeah every
you so what you do and this is why if
you're if you're writtenhouse is a
lawyer you're thinking man I have
indigestion things have been going on
for a long time looking like we're not
going to get a not guilty if we roll the
dice again we have every witness now we
know what they're going to say yeah so
we know what our opening argument or
closing our argument is going to be you
have the test now the judge knows this
yeah the judge when when they the right
house defense filed a motion for
mistrial with prejudice because it had
uh but they did that before
deliberations even started right but now
we're we're a day into deliberations and
they came back on day two and said we'll
take a mistrial with no Prejudice so the
judge has to know they're sweating yeah
no no he knows and the odds have changed
so the way things are going now you
think let's roll again we have all we
have all everybody on the record now all
the evidence that the prosecutor had had
we have it can only get better to the
defense in the second trial so if I'm
them I'm thinking it can only get better
for us yeah if we retry this mofo it can
only get better for us there's a lot of
mistakes they made uh there's a lot of
things the defense the defense they did
I think they did fairly well I think the
state screwed up royally but that means
the defense has all of that knowledge of
their screw-ups they know the state the
state's weaknesses and the things in the
stand that really screwed them up they
have that advantage and they can pull
the jury when there's a mistrial so they
can talk to the jurors who said well hey
you know why'd you think he was like oh
wow they can do that oh yeah yeah why
yeah one you can pull the jury yeah yeah
they can see what arguments work about
that exactly and then you focus group
that wow yeah yeah so a lot of people
you can't do this in criminal trials
because you can't afford them but in big
high injury personal injury they do mock
trials and they bring in juries and then
they say well you know or they'll even
have like buttons where they're like if
you think something's really good like
you push the button and something else
because this is where there's tens of
millions of dollars at stake and if it's
just your life you know it's just
unfortunate so if they have a mistrial
does he go back in jail is he out on
parole on whatever he was he was out on
bails
out of Bale okay they could talk to the
jury they could get a a reshot okay it
would only get better to defense so if
I'm them and I could get a missed trial
without prejudice I know that people are
going to second-guess me but I take that
in a second okay I got to tell you if um
the reason why I don't think I could
probably ever be on a jury is that there
is almost almost no circumstance in
which I would say guilty okay can I can
I jump in here yeah no I'm not allowed
to say this so I'm going to tap dance a
little about it uh there's something
called grand jury and what grand jury is
is like I think 25 or 30 people you're
in paneled for two weeks and you all
have to sit in and this is where you get
uh charges put forward right like they
say a Grandeur will die to hand sandwich
I said to them this part I can't say I'm
an anarchist I won't convict under any
circumstances they said too bad you're
on the grand jury I'm like all right now
that I'm under these circumstances I
have to work within the system it is
very easy I'm giving this advice to
everyone especially on drug charges
juries want to be led so if you are a
possibility of being in a jury and you
say to people look we have no duty to
convict do you really want to ruin this
kid's life because he had some reader
was selling some weed that's going to be
on your conscious then talk about
slavery and how I made this up
like you know they wouldn't convict
unslaved charges back in there they
probably didn't but I was pulling out of
my ass and you'd be amazed at how
receptive people are to letting people
walk when someone makes a coaching case
for them and when that D.A walks back in
the room and you say we're not returning
any charges they're baffled but all it
takes is that one person on that grand
jury to sway everybody else and make a
coaching argument but it's not just it's
not just that people want to be swayed
it's that many rnpcs a lot of people are
there like I don't want to be here I got
to go to work the game's on but they do
want to do the right thing for sure and
your job is to tell them what that is as
a leader when you say we should not
return indictment so so my point was if
I'm on a jury
and they say you know like here's a guy
who's in his home he defended himself
and the state says we think that he
actually intended to commit harm I'd be
like because I'm not I'm like very
similar to your uh ideology however I
say almost none because if I'm on a jury
and it's very very oh yeah yeah very
clear-cut like Rosenbaum I'd be like
guilty guilty guilty or there's cases
where like if someone like literally
raped or killed someone it's it's well
it depends if there's victimless yeah
exactly I'm sure I've heard stories
about the free state project whenever
they have Gatherings that whenever they
find out someone has jury duty they all
celebrate and get really happy because
they know it's an opportunity to nullify
whatever laws they don't believe in
personally and you know a lot of people
they get the jury duty to notice they're
like oh crap I don't want to do this
they feel bad about this but you have an
opportunity to raise your voice and
actually make an argument that could
have severe ramifications for the law on
where you live and there's a thing
called the victimless crimes do the
research on it do the homework on it
because if there isn't a victim there's
no reason the state should be going
after individuals and I will never
convict on a drug charge no matter what
yeah my choice the judge could say if
the state has proven their case that
this man was in possession of Acts you
must return a guilty of verdict and I'll
say no I won't no you won't you don't
have to yeah when people give like very
addictive drugs to children I get a
little nervous because I'm pretty wide
open on drugs kids are different kids
are different that's why I say almost
quote that I would say in the instance
of fentanyl if someone is giving
fentanyl to people and he knows they're
dying but that's poisoning them that's
not to give them drugs
yeah I mean that's but that's why it's
hard it's easy to say never nope nope no
no no no no Lydia that's not a drug
charge that's a murder that's
interesting that you consider fentanyl
especially in large doses a poison it's
I have noise if I give you a soda but
it's really got arsenic in it exactly
arsenic's not a drug
there's a victim's different yeah I in
almost any circumstance where a person
choose is I would probably not convict
so children are different victims
victimless crimes are almost a guarantee
alike this person was in possession of
this I'd be like I don't care there's
also informed consent so if an event if
if a person wants to take fentanyl that
is that person's right it's his body
it's his choice but someone yeah they of
course shouldn't but if someone puts it
in a substance and the other person
doesn't know about it right that's a
crime obviously something that should be
punished and someone should be held
accountable for their individual actions
I'll I'll put it this way in questions
of individual choice
those kinds of Trials and almost never
going you'd never get me to commit on
anything and this is a great opportunity
for everyone to Save a Life not only
that that's true but with Kyle
Rittenhouse you know why there's no
argument they could make in court to
convince me to convict I'm not saying
you can't convince me that Kyle was
wrong I certainly don't think he was
wrong I think that there's reasons he
shouldn't have been there for sure but I
believe he was defending himself and I
think there are a lot of issues at play
but the reason I would never convict
almost ever on a self-defense issue is
because it is better that 100 guilty
persons Go free than one innocent person
suffer yes
yeah I look I understand the risks I
understand the risks of releasing a
hundred guilty persons but I will not be
party to A system that imprisons the
innocent the thing is releasing guilty
people is what happened he's fighting
off pedophiles and assailants yeah
yep yeah Rosenbaum was released that day
yeah well so there's a question about
that some people have said he was in a
mental hospital
but some people are saying they can't
find the records of that and they
haven't found the documentation proving
that some people say it was a jail but
again it's still very unclear either way
my view is like I think
it's it's shocking to me how inhuman our
legal system has become and I've always
been this way Tim sort of yeah yes I
agree with you to a great degree but
when we had a very very uh small when
our communities were very very small and
everyone knew each other it was very
different judge judge Smith was not set
in Walter's kid to prison for the rest
of his life because he was in possession
he's gonna be like aren't you Bill
aren't you Walter's kid what are you
doing coming down here with this stuff
if I see you I see your dad down at the
pub I'm gonna tell him what for we're
giving you probation or whatever today
the cop walks over says I don't know you
I don't care tell the judge big city
what happened problem with density when
the prosecutor if the prosecutor to find
evidence of of Innocence would they
would they still go for the guilty
verdict or are they do they have a duty
to be like well that's called the Brady
violation so that that again goes to
evidence uh the prosecutor has a duty so
there's I don't want to go too far on
the weeds with you guys but there are
two different ways to do this one is you
have constitutionally the prosecutor has
to disclose any evidence that could go
to guilt or mitigation at sentencing so
if they know you're in a set they have a
duty to do it some states have which is
called the open file law so if you're a
prosecutor you just have to give your
file to the defense there that way you
can't say well I don't think this piece
of evidence is really going to be what's
called exculpatory evidence uh it's not
exculpatory so you don't even give them
that choice and most people like me
Advocate open are most people who are
civil Libertarians Advocate open files
if you're gonna whatever you have you
have to get rid of the fence right
because your duty is to do justice
that's the the myth is that you know if
you're a lawyer and you're suing me in a
litigation case your job is only to your
client you don't know anything to me but
the idea is prosecutors have a duty to
quote unquote do justice it's all fake
you know what you're saying though is is
is always been like it's always been bad
yeah but but you know what's sad to me
prosecutors are supposed to are they
supposed to seek Justice that's the
point of prosecution right then they
have grand juries which is okay we're
gonna impanel regular people to see if
they agree we should bring charges and
it's all broken yeah well there's
another aspect to this when people go to
jail they come out way worse jail is
usually a university for criminals where
they learn how to do more criminal and
activities and network with other people
uh and and they come out of that place a
lot worse than they came in and they
become more destructive towards society
and it's a it's a cycle where they keep
going in and out yes in and out and and
the system not only tortures them not
only uh you know deprives them and and
especially with the January 6th uh
people who are were sent to Jail the
inhumane
situations that they're put in cells
that are flooded with sewage uh denied
basic medical attention denied even
proper food getting beaten by guards
we're talking about a system that
corrupts a human being and robs them of
their life so so and again there are
some really bad people out there that
they deserve punishment but a lot of
times what they get in the prison system
is not that I think it's very
unfortunate that when you talk about
having better prison conditions for
prisoners a lot of people who are
conservatively like well they shouldn't
have done this throw lock them up throw
away the key God help you if uh whatever
this Prosecutor's name decides you
should be throwing away the king well
they're in jail right now they're
they're called the January 6th I don't I
don't like the idea of deserve
punishment I don't like a a justice
system that is actually just a
punishment or retribution system I look
at people who do bad things and say how
can we make them not do a bad thing in
the future and then welcome them back
into the warm loving bosom of society
but then you guys were just saying that
you define people by the lowest moment
though right some people yes and some
people go to prison right no no but
that's the whole idea though is in a way
you you have to choose do you want do
you want retribution do you want
Redemption how do you find Redemption
yeah but I'm not saying it's it's a
zero-sum game some people are not worthy
of redemption and I I think we can try
or we can say of people like Rosenbaum
who committed atrocities we say this guy
should probably be locked up forever was
that what happened when someone like
that does get released well that's why
if you asked me and other people
like uh you know people have thought
about these issues we send way too many
people to prison but we don't send
violent criminals away long enough right
exactly right yeah yeah in both ways
yeah it's like we got to sharpen the
curve you know the very violent get more
time and most people get less thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time